fifteen years though tell me how does it
feel to know you're about to become
extinct I guess time will tell
hi everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash season 5 episode 21 video so
obviously next week is gonna be the
finale so I'll address what's going on
with crisis on Infinite Earths in arrows
final season because it's all connected
to crisis and the stuff that's gonna be
happening during the crossover this fall
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the easter-egg
videos we do Marvel and DC every week
this is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
about the episode on the video starting
with top 10 WTF and Easter eggs so
number 10 reverse flashes countdown
clock so the episode begins as reverse
flashes clock hits zero the guard that
we've been seeing all season comes in
he's like I'm gonna miss torturing you
so much with the very thing that gives
you powers he's basically confirming
that the red lightning that we've been
seeing then torture reverse flash with
for the last 15 years we've seen it in a
couple episodes his actual negative
Speed Force energy the first time we saw
it I noticed that it was red I was like
why does it look exactly like reverse
flashes Speed Force lightning but
they're just confirming that that's
exactly what it is they claim that
they're gonna use it to kill him
eventually I guess they're just gonna
give him a fatal dose of energy and I
guess the reason why that's able to kill
him because he'd normally would channel
that Speed Force energy is just because
of the effects of the dagger dampening
his powers you get a really crazy WTF
scene of grace listening to mine space
cicada something that she's probably
just created through all of her years of
trauma I don't think there's actual
cicada in there even though her powers
work in a really weird way number nine
was mirror masters gun they actually
introduced that in last week's episode I
didn't do a video for last week just
because there was so much other bigger
stuff going on into episode was a bit of
a snooze fest but the really important
thing that they did was introduce mere
masters gun from the comics and they
also had a Josh Williamson Easter Egg -
he was one of the street names and if
you don't know who Josh Williamson is
he's the person that's been riding the
flash rebirth comic ever since the start
of flash rebirth the last couple of
years they've been doing a lot of Easter
eggs and storylines pulling from his
flash rebirth run like Nora is kind of a
version of Mina
with the negative speed force she even
wore purple in last week's episode while
she was poisoned with negative Speed
Force energy so she almost looked
exactly like Mina there's a lot of
time-travel going on in that comic book
storyline too that they're pulling
elements from but they're not doing the
exact flash rebirth comic book story the
funny thing about the mirror gun is that
they totally don't understand how it
works they only know that it atomizes
things and it's a way to get rid of
cicadas dagger like okay we'll destroy
it with the mirror gun but when they
test it on the original dark matter
satellite wreckage that crashed earth
and caused all these problems so long
ago it just disappears into nothingness
it seemingly disappears they look at
each other they're like hey wait a
minute what happened to the satellite
where'd it go who cares let's go on to
the next problem that there sounds like
a tease for the mirror world and future
mere master things if they introduced
the second version of mirror master from
the comics McCullough tech were the
people that created the gun as a weapon
but Evan McCullough was the second
version of Mir master to wear the mantle
in the comics he was actually created by
Grant Morrison and appeared in an animal
band comic before he became a flash
villain the version of mirror master
that the flash TV show did in previous
seasons was the original version Sam
Scudder so they're just moving forward
in the Rogues they kind of did the same
thing with the other rogues too like we
started with whether wizard that we have
whether which his daughter so it's all
just part of their grand plan to slowly
introduce younger or newer iterations of
the Rogues my guess is though that we
probably won't see an Evan McCullough
mirror master until a future season if
they introduced him at all but the
mirror gun is just a really big deal in
the way that they're using it in the
last couple of episodes number eight is
future Grace's plan to eliminate all the
metahumans she's using the quantum
tunnel that they talked about during the
episode in combination with the atomizer
in a viral version of the cure to just
dispersed across Central City and get
rid of thousands of metahumans and they
just move on from territory to territory
slowly eliminating them all over the
world when Sherlock was trying to send
rené Adler to his earth they also
dropped a bit of a teaser to like don't
let Sakata know that there are other
Earth's out there because she'd go crazy
one way or another they'll have to sew
up the rené Adler plot in the finale so
either that'll become a thing for cicada
like they're trying to drop a teaser
like oh maybe cicada will try to escape
to another earth before they get rid of
her but number seven was setting up Joe
West as the few
captain of the police department I fell
like that whole storyline like him
managing that crisis is just a tease
that he will become the official captain
of the CCPD in a future season if you
remember way back during season three
when Barry went to the future for the
first time I think it was episode nine
where'd he saw iris get killed by avatar
for the first time before that happened
there was a little news blurb about Joe
West being honored and I think it was
calling him the captain of the CCPD at
the time that was only a few years into
the future
so who knows when they're gonna pay that
off but because captain Singh is still a
really young man I think the only way to
clear a path for that is if they have
secada or somebody else kill him on the
TV show maybe in the finale maybe
they'll do it in a future season number
six was then introducing another one of
Cisco's arch-nemesis from the Godspeed
episode so they talk about Allen's
laboratory they introduced that idea
during the Godspeed episode in the
future where they go to all ins
laboratory they talk to a couple of the
people that's right out of the firestorm
comics but in this context he was
Cisco's roommate and apparently a really
crappy student when they were in college
together
so Cisco's just really pissed off about
that so I don't know if they're just
trying to connect some dots but they've
been changing the timelines so much that
you have to remember that a lot of what
they're doing today will affect Nora's
future so when she goes back eventually
things will be very very different I
think there are a couple of things that
they're gonna try and pay off but
remember a crisis on Infinite Earths in
the background we have this
reverse-flash storyline so there's a
whole bunch of storylines that they have
to wrap up in the finale but number five
is Ralph's timeline explainer suddenly
he gets super smart he tried to explain
the beginning of the season and they'd
made a really funny moment of it what if
we called it a mini verse and they all
like face-palming it's called the
multiverse Ralph he's the one that
connects the dots about reverse flashes
planned but short term he's trying to
account for all the changes of the
timelines so what happened is is in the
original version of the timeline there
was a version of cicada that became a
problem berry defeated him like he
defeats all the other rogues they went
on about their business but you have
crisis on Infinite Earths in 2024 where
Barrie disappears per all the newspapers
so Nora gets the idea from reverse-flash
to come back and also the idea to help
him defeat the satellite at the end of
season 4 that creates a new timeline
where the original version of cicada
does not become cicada Orlan becomes
cicada that second time line leads to
grace event
taking the mantle once she's old enough
she kills a bunch of people in the
future and is bad they try to stop her
but then eventually they create another
new timeline when that version of grace
comes back and then kills
Orlin before he can grow up and pass the
mantle to her so remember when we get
the Godspeed episode it was all Nora in
the future
that was before grace came back in time
and changed the timelines so if Nora
were to go back right now things would
already be very different but it sounds
like they're gonna be even more changes
to the timeline before the end of the
finale number four was then putting Nora
in reverse flashes containment device
from season one while she was dueling
minds with grace wielding the negative
Speed Force the only thing that I didn't
like about this Nora storyline her in
the episode was when Barry and iris went
all crazy town banana pants trying to
bench her like no we don't want you
helping out even though we need
everybody we can get all the stuff that
Barry's done being the flash with Nora's
version of the flash teaching her new
skills that's been a lot of fun but all
the homie parenting stuff that they've
been doing has just been way too
saccharine is a huge snooze fest I just
hope they moved past it as fast as
possible one of the other funny things
about the episode too is when Nora was
in Grace's mind space you see the
version of grace that's just going crazy
chewing through every bit of scenery
that she can get it was a bit of a
cringe fest but maybe they were writing
it that way on purpose like we want this
to purposefully seem like she's doing a
lot of bad acting but number three grace
busts into the Central City Police
Department pulling a Supergirl brow
makes a Supergirl reference she uses
everyone's powers to charge up her
device they don't have much of a fight
scene they kind of brawl it out for just
a brief second while Cisco is trying to
disarm the bomb so number two Cisco
disarms the atomizer while Barry is
being thrown all over the place the
weird thing about his takedown of grace
is that you wonder like how powerful is
she why wasn't he able to pull a move
like this earlier has he been taking it
easy on her because like she says she
doesn't need the dagger to take them
down a lot of her abilities are innate
she just uses the dagger to take away
other people's powers but of course
number one reverse flashes grand plan is
revealed rau finishes putting the pieces
together just as her getting ready to
vaporize the dagger with the mere gun or
to zap it to the MIR world because like
they say they have no idea what happens
to things when they shoot it with the
Mira gun they just disappear but
seemingly disappear into mirrors so I
think that's just for
shadowing mirror world but either way
you learned that in the future the
reason why grace didn't have the dagger
is is because the Central City Police
Department was using it to nullify
reverse Flash's powers for the last 15
years so if it wasn't clear what his
plan was
he was gonna have them destroy the
dagger in the past so that in the future
this version of the dagger would just
completely disappear would vanish from
this part of the timeline and his powers
would be reactivated but like I said the
finale is next week there's only gonna
be 22 episodes this season instead of 23
it's the same for arrow supposedly the
monitor is gonna guest star in the arrow
finale and it'll have something to do
with the bargain that Oliver made and
that'll push into crisis on Infinite
Earths if they do a special monitor
crisis teaser in next week's arrow
episode then I'll just include that in
my flash finale so no worries let me
know in the comments though what do you
think about all this mirror gun do you
think we're gonna see the Evan
McCullough mirror master in a future
season and what do you think reverse
flash is gonna do that will also help
tease crisis on Infinite Earths because
they're doing it on arrow they'll
probably do something like that on the
flash as well there was even more new
spider-man far from home footage they
dropped in the last day so I'll do a new
video for that soon obviously Game of
Thrones and all the Avengers stuff is
going on in the background leave your
video requests in the comments below big
news too while I was finishing this
video this morning they dropped the
Watchmen HBO teaser trailer that's not
gonna premiere to the fall but HBO is
doing a watchman TV series so it is
gonna be hardcore I'll try to do a
trailer video for that sometime too in
the next couple of days what are you two
talking about oh nothing to see end of
the world
while you wait for everything click here
for my spider-man far from home trailer
with all the multiverse stuff and click
here for my Game of Thrones season 8
episode 5 trailer video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]